hey guys my name is just much all it is
the 13th of April today and you're
watching game Star News a new Monster
Hunter RPG has been announced for 3d so
if you're keen on the series here are
all the details the game entitled
Monster Hunter stories will let players
take on the role of writers instead of
the traditional hunters as riders you'll
get to mount up on monsters and ride
them around the unreasonably colorful
world of monster hunter and an ultimate
trailer is now live on gamespot where
you can get a good sense of the gameplay
and a solid last lesson on the
repercussions of stealing eggs from
towering dragon monster stories is
expected to land in Japan in 2016 with
no word yet on a Western release
Destiny's upcoming expansion house of
wolves now has a release date Bungie
have now officially confirmed that the
second expansion will land on May
nineteen for xbox 360 xbox one ps3 and
ps4 Bungie have also dropped a prologue
trailer for the expansion so you can get
a feel for the awoken storyline that
you'll most likely be ignoring in favor
of leveling and scouting for endlessly
farmable treasure cave exploits next up
for k resolution capabilities for the
witcher 3 and GTA 5 pc are set to
impress i really can't do the images
justice in this video but they're
totally worth checking out witcher 3
does set a project red have released for
new images of the game in 4k resolution
which looked totally stunning of course
you'll need a meaty PC and a 4k monitor
to get the full experience but these
lovely shots may be enough to sway some
of you figure out silver locks a pack of
dire wolves and the back of a horse like
you've never seen it before by heading
to our story on gamespot as the GTA 5
Rockstar calling their game in 4k a
quote I opener Rockstar told pc gamer
that it really does make you look at the
world differently although with the
required pc specs not a lot of us are
going to be getting that perspective the
dev have said to run the game on
4k display at 30 frames per second
you'll need at minimum and AMD HD 7870
or nvidia gtx 760 with 2 gigabytes of
vram to be able to run the game at 4k
resolution at 60 frames per second
you'll need a high-end sli or crossfire
set up let me know down in the comments
if you're keen to get into PC gaming at
4k and why or why not you can add to
gamespot we've got stories on the orders
photo mode and the Xbox one getting a
price drop in the UK that is it for me
today thanks for sticking around be sure
to leave me your thoughts and I'll catch
the same time tomorrow